Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. He always took the Bible for his guide, and he liked little boys to walk by his side. He preferred their company more so than men, because he knew there was less guile in them. And in his conversation he was modest and plain, denouncing all pleasures he considered sinful and vain, and in battle he carried no weapon but a small cane, whilst the bullets fell around him like a shower of rain. He burnt the debtors' books that were imprisoned in Khartoum, and freed them from a dismal prison gloom. Those that were imprisoned for debts they couldn't pay, and sent them rejoicing on their way.
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。如果您想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。他总是以《圣经》为指南，喜欢让小男孩陪在他身边。他更喜欢和他们在一起而不是成年人，因为他知道他们身上少有诡诈。在言谈中，他朴实无华，谴责所有他认为罪恶和虚浮的快乐，在战场上，他只带一根小手杖，没有武器，周围的子弹像阵雨一样落下来。他烧毁了喀土穆被关押债务人的账簿，将他们从阴暗的监狱阴霾中解放出来。那些因为还不起债务而入狱的人，被他送上了充满喜悦的回家之路。
Beautiful, Tom. Absolutely beautiful reading of a brilliant poem. Thank you very much. Further verses there from William McGonagall's great poem marking the death of General Gordon and Khartoum in 1885. And Dominic, in the first part, we were looking at the first part of Gordon's career up to the point where he goes to the Sudan for the first time. So he's a great hero. He's the Chinese Gordon, he's called. He spent six years in Gravesend helping the Wangs, the little boys who were mentioned in that poem there.
太美了，汤姆。这是一首精彩诗作的绝美朗读。非常感谢。刚才那是威廉·麦哥纳高尔（William McGonagall）的伟大诗作中的更多诗节，这首诗是为了纪念1885年戈登将军在喀土穆去世。多米尼克，在第一部分中，我们回顾了戈登职业生涯的前半段，直到他第一次去苏丹。所以他是一位伟大的英雄。人们称他为“中国戈登”。他在格雷夫森德度过了六年，帮助了那首诗中提到的小男孩——王（Wang）。
Yeah. And if you think that's suspicious, well, you can hear our that uh in in yesterday's episode if you haven't already um so dominic so february 1874 yes what's going on so there's this extraordinary situation um in the sudan basically so egypt which is nominally part of the ott Empire, but de facto kind of isn't, is pretty much, it has the Sudan almost as a kind of a possession of its own. But in turn, Egypt is kind of answering to Britain because it owes Britain loads of money. So what you have in the Sudan is the Sudanese economy. Sudan is incredibly poor. The Sudanese economy depends largely on slavery.
是的。如果你觉得这很可疑，好吧，如果你还没听的话，可以在昨天的节目里听到……嗯……所以，多米尼克，1874年2月，是的，发生了什么？所以苏丹基本上出现了这样一种非同寻常的局势——嗯，名义上属于奥斯曼帝国的埃及，但实际上又不算，它差不多……几乎把苏丹当作自己的领地。但反过来，埃及又某种程度上听命于英国，因为它欠了英国巨额债务。所以在苏丹，你看到的是苏丹的经济。苏丹极其贫穷。苏丹的经济很大程度上依赖于奴隶制。
So the slavery is being abolished all over the world and the slave trade being stamped out. The East African slave trade is still going very strong. In fact, it's arguably stronger than ever because slavery has been stamped out elsewhere. So there's loads of money to be made from slavery and the the khedive of egypt the ruler of egypt i think basically uses the sort of anti-slavery sentiment he says well i want to stamp out slavery too actually what he really wants is to reassert his control over the Sudan. And what he wants to do is to get
因此，世界各地都在废除奴隶制，并在根除奴隶贸易。东非奴隶贸易依然非常猖獗。事实上，可以说比以往任何时候都更强烈，因为其他地方的奴隶制已经被根除了。因此，通过奴隶制可以赚取巨额财富，埃及赫迪夫（Khedive），也就是埃及的统治者，我认为他基本上利用了这种反奴隶制的情绪，他说：“嗯，其实我也想根除奴隶制。”但实际上，他真正想要的是重新确立他对苏丹的控制。他想要做的是
somebody in, an outsider, a Brit, to come and run the Sudan for him and impose control, set up a whole trading network. And the Khedive says, I'd like you to stamp out the slave trade as well. So it's a bit, a bit, perhaps,
找一个局外人，一个英国人来，替他管理苏丹，强加控制，建立一个完整的贸易网络。赫迪夫说：“我也希望你顺便根除奴隶贸易。”所以这有点，也许有点……
like the Iraqi exiles from Saddam Hussein's regime going to American neoconservatives and saying would you please come and would you please come and kick out Saddam I suppose that's a slightly yes it's a slight stretch but I can see what you're saying it's basically yes it's it's getting an outsider into that that so we've done an episode on on 9-11 we've done an episode on Napoleon in Egypt and this is kind of midway between that but it's getting an outsider into it. It's just that, so we've done an episode on 9-11, we've done an episode on Napoleon in Egypt, and this is kind of midway between that. But we are now moving into the very, very contested,
就像萨达姆·侯赛因政权的伊拉克流亡分子去找美国新保守主义者，说“请你们来，请你们把萨达姆赶走吧”——我想这有点……是的，这有点牵强，但我能明白你的意思。基本上，是的，这就是把一个局外人带入到……所以我们做过一期关于9·11的节目，我们做过一期关于拿破仑在埃及的节目，这有点介于两者之间，但这就是把一个局外人带入其中。只是——所以我们做过一期关于9·11的节目，我们做过一期关于拿破仑在埃及的节目，这有点介于两者之间。但我们现在正在进入……西方与伊斯兰关系中非常、非常充满争议、复杂且极其矛盾的历史。
complex and very ambivalent history of the relationship of the West to Islam. That's right. I mean, and also the whole slavery issue right i mean yeah well well absolutely because um the the impetus for anti-slavery is christian it's absolutely powered by exactly the kind of experience of being born again of evangelical certitude that gordon has also bought into so gordon is passionately opposed to slavery. I mean, basically for the second half of his life, he spends all his time thinking about how he'd love to be a crusader against
没错。我的意思是，还有整个奴隶制问题，对吧？我的意思是，是的，好吧，完全是这样，因为……嗯，反奴隶制的动力是基督教的，它绝对是由那种重生的经历、戈登也接受的福音派确信所驱动的。所以戈登对奴隶制有着极大的反对。我的意思是，基本上在他生命的后半段，他所有的时间都在思考他多么渴望成为一个反对奴隶制的……
slavery and stamp it out and so on. And that means he ends up being used or almost used by a succession of quite dodgy people. So one of those that could even later on Leopold II Belgian in the Congo who wants to use Gordon as a tool with anti-slavery being the pretext. And elements within British foreign policy establishment and military establishment as well. Because one of the paradoxes of Britain's absolutely key role in the abolition of the slave trade, which is done for overtly moralistic reasons. I mean, I say overtly, I mean, they are done for moral reasons. It's forced through and led and conducted
十字军战士，将它根除等等。这意味着他最终被一连串相当靠不住的人利用了，或者说几乎被利用了。其中之一就是后来的比利时国王利奥波德二世（Leopold II in the Congo），他想把戈登当作工具，以反奴隶制为借口。英国外交政策建制派和军事建制派内部的元素也是如此。因为英国在废除奴隶贸易中发挥了绝对关键的作用，这是一个悖论，而这出于明显的道德主义原因。我的意思是，我说明显的，我的意思是，它们是出于道德原因完成的。它是被那些坚信自己在执行上帝意志的人……
by people who passionately believe that they're doing God's will. But that very sense of moral agency then becomes a further tool of imperialism, because it provides a moral sanction for Britain to intervene. And of course, the Protestant evangelical motivation for this is not something that sits easily with Islam, which has a body of texts, of sayings, of prescriptions that, in the opinion of Muslims derive directly from God and so Gordon's understanding of God is written on his heart it's experienced as as a process of being born again he doesn't he reads the Bible but he understands the Bible through that prism for Muslims there is this great body of law that for centuries and centuries and centuries has said that slavery is legitimate.
强行推动、领导和执行的。但这种道德代理感本身后来成为了帝国主义的又一个工具，因为它为英国的干预提供了道德制裁。当然，新教福音派对此的动机与伊斯兰教并不能轻易契合。伊斯兰教拥有一套经文、圣训和戒律，在穆斯林的观点中，这些直接源自真主。因此，戈登对上帝的理解写在他的心上，它是作为一种重生的过程体验到的，他阅读《圣经》，但他透过这个视角去理解《圣经》。对于穆斯林来说，存在着这样一个庞大的法律体系，几个世纪、几个世纪、几个世纪以来一直宣称奴隶制是合法的。
And so there is, I mean, I suppose you'd call it a clash of civilizations. I mean, certainly a clash of moral perspectives. Yeah, I think that's fair. I think Gordon doesn't quite know, even at this stage. So this isn't the sort of fatal trip to the Sudan. This is a much earlier one. But even at this stage, there's a sense that he doesn't quite know what he's getting into. Well, he's actually he's going as governor general of the equator, isn't he?
所以，我的意思是，我想你可以称之为文明冲突。我的意思是，这肯定是一种道德观点的冲突。是的，我认为这很公平。我认为戈登甚至在这个阶段都还不太清楚状况。所以这不是那种去苏丹的致命之旅。这是一次早得多的旅行。但即使在这个阶段，也有这样一种感觉，他并不完全清楚自己卷入了什么。嗯，实际上他是作为赤道总督去的，不是吗？
Yeah. So it's quite a slightly weird story. So basically, one of the Khadive's ministers, who's a guy called Nubar Pasha, he meets Gordon at a dinner party in Constantinople. And he's impressed by him. And he asked somebody afterwards, who is that? And somebody says, oh, that's Chinese Chinese Gordon don't know who he is and he gets a book about him and he reads this book by written by a French royalist which says oh what a tremendous person Gordon is and the minister says oh this is a this is the kind of person we're looking for you know let's get him
是的。所以这是一个有点奇怪的故事。基本上，赫迪夫的一位大臣，一个叫努巴尔·帕夏（Nubar Pasha）的人，在君士坦丁堡的一次晚宴上遇到了戈登。他对其印象深刻。他事后问别人：“那是谁？”有人说：“哦，那是中国戈登。”（人们）不知道他是谁。然后他拿到了一本关于戈登的书，读了这本由一位法国保皇党人写的书，书中说：“哦，戈登是多么了不起的人啊。”这位大臣说：“哦，这就是我们要找的那种人，你知道的，让我们把他……”
in to come down and at first Gordon's as you say just sent down to what's called equatoria which is kind of now south sudan north uganda so it's the bottom bit of of the sudan and that's the bit that basically the sudanese slave hunters prey upon they they are looking for kind of black african slaves that they will send north and east and so on which again they've been doing since the eighth century but gordon thinks this is unconscionable he's there to stamp it out and to and in doing so to reassert the power of cairo so he goes down and he's basically ends up being given more and more power so by 1877 three years after he's arrived he's been made governor general of the whole of sudan that sounds like a very grand job but basically he's doing it on his own with a handful of people
请来。起正如你所说，戈登最初被派往所谓的“赤道省”（Equatoria），也就是现在的南苏丹和乌干达北部，也就是苏丹的最南端。那是苏丹奴隶猎人肆意掠夺的地方。他们在寻找黑人非洲奴隶，要把他们送到北方和东方等等。同样，他们从8世纪以来就一直在这么做。但戈登认为这是不可容纳的，他是去根除它的，并且以此来重新确立开罗的权力。于是他去了那里，结果他最终被赋予了越来越多的权力。因此，到了1877年，也就是他到达三年后，他被任命为整个苏丹的总督。这听起来是一个非常崇高的职位，但基本上他是在只有少数人的情况下独自一人……
kind of trudging around this colossal, colossal country. I mean, a country basically the size of Western Europe. And kind of horrible. Yeah. I mean, the conditions are unbelievably tough. They've got kind of permanent dysentery. There's no water.
在这个庞大无比、庞大无比的国家里艰难跋涉。我的意思是，一个基本上有西欧那么大的国家。而且极其糟糕。是的。我的意思是，条件极其艰苦。他们一直患有痢疾。没有水。
That's incredibly hot. Well, again, we've... So we've listened straight to his biography of him, which, you know, is in so many ways so damning of him so so negative and yet again and again there are phrases that that kind of are expressive of admiration so he just so straight she describes uh gordon in equatoria the confused and horrible country the appalling climate the maddening insects and the loathsome diseases the indifference of subordinates and superiors, the savagery of the slave traders and the hatred of the inhabitants. So a kind of a gruelling place for someone to be. And he's fascinating,
热得难以置信。好吧，同样，我们……所以我们直接听了他关于戈登的传记，你知道，这本书在很多方面对他的批判如此之多、如此负面，然而一次又一次，有些词句……表达了一种钦佩。所以他这样描述……他直接描述了……戈登在赤道省的经历：混乱而可怕的国家、骇人听闻的气候、令人发狂的昆虫和令人作呕的疾病、下属和上司的冷漠、奴隶贩子的野蛮以及居民的仇恨。对任何人来说，这都是一个令人精疲力竭的地方。而且他很迷人，
I mean, from contemporary sensibility. So obviously his role in stopping the slave trade, I mean, was not to approve really. But he's also very hostile to ivory trading. He is, because a lot of the slave trade is driven by ivory. So they need people. There's a huge demand for ivory in the West. And a lot of the slaves are carrying loads of ivory to the coast. Yeah. And stopping the two kind of goes hand in hand.
我是说，从当代的敏感度来看。显然他在制止奴隶贸易方面的角色，我的意思是，并不是真正赞同。但他对象牙贸易也非常敌视。他确实如此，因为许多奴隶贸易都是由象牙驱动的。所以他们需要人。西方对象牙的需求巨大。许多奴隶扛着大量的象牙去海岸。是的。而制止这两者有点是相辅相成的。
So actually, Gordon is a conservationist hero, as well as an anti-slavery one when he's worried he's worried that the um the rapacity for ivory will wipe elephants out and he's right seems a very 21st century perspective so but he's sort of he's a failure though isn't he ultimately he's disappointed he basically says i can't rely on any of the egyptians they're completely corrupt well because he he the only way to stop the slave trade is to stop it at source i sorry is to stop the market so he can try and you know basically he's kind of uh whack-a-mole yeah because you know he'll close off one avenue and another one will sprout up um you know it's got to be he recognizes it's got to be stopped in Arabia and Constantinople or whatever.
所以实际上，戈登不仅是一个反奴隶制的英雄，当他担心时，他还是一个自然保护主义英雄，他担心对象牙的贪婪会消灭大象，他是对的。这看起来是一个非常21世纪的视角。所以，但他某种程度上……他是一个失败者，不是吗？最终他很失望。他基本上说：“我不能指望任何埃及人，他们完全腐败。”好吧，因为他……制止奴隶贸易的唯一方法是从源头上制止它，对不起，是制止市场，所以他可以尝试……你知道，基本上他有点像在玩打地鼠游戏。是的，因为你知道，他会封锁一条途径，另一条途径就会冒出来……你知道，他认识到必须在阿拉伯和君士坦丁堡等地制止它。
That's the only way to halt it. Yeah. And he's a very, something quite forlorn about him, I think, at this point. You know, as you say, he's in terrible conditions. He's very lonely. He's reading his Bible for three hours a day to kind of console himself as he's sort of riding his camels around the Sudan or taking ship down the Nile or whatever.
那是制止它的唯一方法。是的。而且他非常……我觉得此时他有一种相当落魄的感觉。你知道，就像你说的，他在恶劣的环境中。他非常孤独。他每天读三个小时的《圣经》来安慰自己，当他在苏丹骑着骆驼四处巡视，或者乘船顺尼罗河而下时。
And then he basically resigns, doesn't he? At the end of 1879, early 1880, he says, I've had enough. I'm out. I'm not getting the support I need. But that's helped to make him even more of a celebrity, the fact that he's basically been running a massive country. So then Leopold ii this belgian bad guy i'm sorry to say uh asks him to come and run the congo for him but hasn't he
然后他基本上辞职了，不是吗？在1879年底、1880年初，他说：“我受够了。我退出。我没有得到我需要的支持。”但这反倒让他变得更加出名，因为他基本上管理了一个庞大的国家。所以接着利奥波德二世，这个比利时恶棍——我很抱歉这么说——邀请他去为他管理刚果。但是他没有……
before that hasn't he gone off to be private secretary to the viceroy of india yeah i think he had an opening offer from leopold leopold keeps asking him okay but he does go to india you're right as the private secretary of lord rippon, who's the viceroy, and he hates it. Absolutely hates it. And he resigns after days. So he arrives in Bombay with the viceroy on kind of a week. And a Zoroastrian, a Parsi, hands over a book of poetry. And Gordon, as the private secretary, has to say,
在那之前，他不是去当印度总督的私人秘书了吗？是的，我想他收到过利奥波德的一个初期邀请，利奥波德一直在邀请他。好吧，但他确实去了印度，你说得对，作为总督里彭勋爵（Lord Ripon）的私人秘书，他讨厌那里。绝对讨厌。几天后他就辞职了。所以他随总督到达孟买大约一个星期。一个祆教徒，一个帕西人，递过来一本诗集。而戈登作为私人秘书，不得不说：
yes, the viceroy will read it with great interest. But no, the viceroy will never read it. And Gordon is so tormented by having to lie about this yes, the viceroy will read it with great interest, but no, the viceroy will never read it. And Gordon is so tormented by having to lie about this that he resigns. Yeah, well, he's a very intense person. I mean, he's not the person you would employ as your PA, basically. Not the kind of person who you'd employ
是的，总督会怀着极大的兴趣阅读它。但其实不，总督永远不会读它。戈登因为不得不对此撒谎而备受折磨……是的，总督会怀着极大的兴趣阅读它。但其实不，总督永远不会读它。而戈登因为不得不对此撒谎而备受折磨，以至于他辞职了。是的，好吧，他是一个非常情绪化的人。我的意思是，他根本不是那种你会雇佣来当私人助理的人。绝对不是那种你会雇佣……
as a spin doctor in Downing Street, certainly. No, no, that's definitely true. He wouldn't laugh about illicit parties. No. No, he wouldn't. That's definitely true. He wouldn't laugh about illicit parties. No. No, he wouldn't. Well, he hates dinner parties. I mean, that's the other thing. Well, he says, when he's in Khartoum at the end.
作为唐宁街的政治化妆师的人，绝对不是。不，不，这绝对是真的。他不会对非法的派对付之一笑。不。不，他不会的。这绝对是真的。他不会对非法的派对付之一笑。不。不，他不会的。好吧，他讨厌晚宴。我的意思是，这是另一回事。好吧，他在最后的喀土穆时说：
People are constantly asking him to dinner parties. When he's in Khartoum at the end of his story, he says, you know, one of the great things about being here is that I don't have to go to any dinner parties. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. When is the famous thing where he meets up with a French guy who takes him to the opera house in Naples? Oh, I didn't see this.
人们不断邀请他去参加晚宴。当他故事末尾身处喀土穆时，他说：“你知道，在这里的一大好处就是我不用去参加任何晚宴。”是的。是的。是的。什么时候发生那个著名的故事：他遇到一个法国人，带他去那不勒斯歌剧院？哦，我没看到这个。
Where they see female ballet dancers. And Gordon's so appalled. He says, if this is civilization, it can go. Keep it. And then according to the Frenchman, he comes round to see Gordon later. And Gordon is kind of sitting there with his trousers open, lying on the bed, drinking, necking brandy. I don't believe that. That's Rudolph Giuliani, surely.
他们在那里看到了女性芭蕾舞演员。戈登惊恐万分。他说：“如果这就是文明，那它就可以滚蛋了。留着它吧。”然后据那个法国人说，他后来过来看望戈登。而戈登正敞着裤子坐在那儿，躺在床上，喝酒，猛灌白兰地。我不相信那是真的。那绝对是鲁迪·朱利安尼（Rudolph Giuliani）。
But from your description. Well, it's a guy called Joseph Reinhardt. At the time, he was very enthusiastic about Gordon. But then 30 or 40 years. And this then. We haven't really mentioned very enthusiastic about Gordon, but then 30 or 40 years, and this then... We haven't really mentioned the issue about Gordon and drink. So there are stories that were put about later on. We had a question, actually.
但根据你的描述……好吧，那是一个叫约瑟夫·莱inhardt（Joseph Reinhardt）的人。当时他非常热衷于戈登。但随后的三四十年里……而这……我们还没有真正提到……热衷于戈登，但随后的三四十年里，而这……我们还没有真正提到过戈登与酒的问题。所以有一些后来流传的故事。其实我们有一个问题。
One of our listeners asked us a question. Man of Gwent says, Winston Churchill, we're out of Gordon. Of course, there is no doubt that Gordon, as a political figure figure was absolutely hopeless. He was so erratic, capricious, utterly unreliable. His mood changed so often. His temper was abominable.
我们的一位听众问了一个问题。来自格温特的男子（Man of Gwent）说：“温斯顿·丘吉尔，我们对戈登不甚了解。当然，毫无疑问，戈登作为一名政治人物绝对是无可救药的。他如此反复无常、喜怒无常、极其不可靠。他的情绪经常变化。他的脾气糟透了。
He was frequently drunk. And yet with all that, he had a tremendous sense of honour and great abilities. I mean, Churchill's basically talking about himself, isn't he? Yes, very much so. But you know where Churchill got that from? From Lord Cromer, Evelyn Baring. talking about himself isn't he yes very much so but you know where he got where churchill got that from from um uh lord cromer evelyn bearing evelyn bearing who's basically the guy who's running egypt yeah and who hated gordon hated gordon so bearing is a source for a lot of the stories that i mean actually most of the stories that um that gordon was a drunk and an alcoholic and also um that he perhaps wasn't entirely all that he should have been sexually.
他经常喝醉。尽管如此，他有着巨大的荣誉感和非凡的能力。”我的意思是，丘吉尔基本上是在谈论他自己，不是吗？是的，非常如此。但你知道丘吉尔是从哪里知道这一点的吗？从克罗默勋爵（Lord Cromer）、埃夫林·巴林（Evelyn Baring）那里……他在谈论他自己，不是吗？是的，非常如此。但你知道他从哪里——丘吉尔从哪里得到这个的吗？从……埃夫林·巴林勋爵那里。埃夫林·巴林，基本上就是那个管理埃及的人。是的。而且他讨厌戈登，讨厌戈登。所以巴林是许多故事的来源——我的意思是，事实上，大多数关于……戈登是个酒鬼和酒徒，还有……
So Baring said of Gordon that he was a queer fellow with a very feminine side to his character. Yes, I saw that. Yeah. Yeah. Baring can't really be trusted, I think. And a lot of Gordon, I mean, Gordon wasn't a drunk. I think you can reasonably say he might sometimes have, you know, in stressful situations, necked a bit of brandy. But I think he was drunk with the Holy Spirit. Yeah, well, I think by and large,
也许他在性取向上并不完全像他应该的那样。所以巴林对戈登的评价是，他是一个性格古怪的人，性格中有着非常女性化的一面。是的，我看到了。是的。是的。我觉得巴林真的不能信赖。而且戈登的很多事情——戈登不是个酒鬼。我想你可以合理地说，他在压力大的情况下，有时可能会猛灌一点白兰地。但我认为他是被圣灵灌醉了。是的，好吧，我想大体上，
most of the people who worked with him said, no, I don't think he was a drunk. I didn't see him drinking to excess. So I think we can probably put that one to bed a little bit. What is true is that Gordon, as time goes on, particularly because he's in these incredibly stressful situations, he is a bit cranky, isn't he? And he's alone with his Bible, and he just keeps reading the Bible.
绝大多数与他共事过的人都说：“不，我不认为他是个酒鬼。我没看到他酗酒过度。”所以我想我们大概可以把这个传闻稍微平息一下。真实的情况是，随着时间的推移，戈登，特别是由于他处于这些压力极其巨大的情况下，他确实变得有点古怪，不是吗？他独自一人和《圣经》在一起，他只是不停地阅读《圣经》。
And making up his own strange ideas. So he's been to the Sudan. I can't remember where. South Africa he goes. He's been to South Africa. He meets Ketoweo, doesn't he? There's this strange point where he goes to Mauritius with the royal engineers. Have you seen this?
并编造出他自己奇怪的想法。所以他去过苏丹。我不记得在哪里了。他去过南非。他见过克特瓦约（Cetshwayo），不是吗？有这么一个奇怪的时刻，他带着皇家工程师去了毛里求斯。你见过这个吗？
Yeah. He goes to the Seychelles, to one of the islands of the Seychelles, where they have these sea coconuts, these double coconuts called Coco de Mer. And Gordon becomes convinced that the trees with the sea, the double coconuts, are the tree of the knowledge of good and evil from the Garden of Eden. He thinks he's found the garden of eden because he says these double coconuts if they're attached to the tree they
是的。他去了塞舌尔，去了塞舌尔的其中一个岛屿，那里有这种海椰子，这种被称为“复椰子”（Coco de Mer）的双椰子。戈登开始确信，长有海椰子、这种双椰子的树，就是伊甸园里善恶知识树。他认为他找到了伊甸园，因为他说这些双椰子如果连在树上，它们……
look like the male organ of generation yeah and if you cut them open they look very much like the female organs of generation so these clearly are what eve and the serpent were getting stuck into or whatever so you can imagine you're getting telegrams about this in the residency at cairo what he tells people this is the thing so the governor of basuto land he told him he said he wrote gordon is as mad as a marcher he's certainly a military genius but about religious matters he is quite mad. And clearly, even Gordon's admiring biographers say, Gordon was going around telling people this. You know, stiff kind of Victorian,
看起来就像男性的生殖器官。是的。如果你把它们切开，它们看起来非常像女性的生殖器官。所以这些显然就是夏娃和蛇一直在纠缠的东西，或者诸如此类。所以你可以想象，你在开罗的总督府里收到关于这的电报时作何感想。他把这告诉了别人，就是这样。所以巴苏陀兰（Basutoland）总督，他告诉他，他写道：“戈登就像三月的野兔一样疯。他当然是个军事天才，但关于宗教问题，他完全疯了。”
worldly kind of governors and generals and stuff. And they're just absolutely bamboozled by it. Yeah, yeah. Well, and also he then goes to the Holy Land, doesn't he? He finds Golgotha, doesn't he?'t he and he finds Golgotha doesn't he he thinks he's found so he claims yes and you can still see it actually in Jerusalem so it's uh the the tomb in the garden so it's not the church of the holy sepulcher right it's basically skull hill is it called skull hill yeah so it's outside the old city and is there any credence for Gordon's
而且很显然，就连戈登那些钦佩他的传记作者也说，戈登到处跟人讲这个。你知道，那些死板的维多利亚时代、世俗气十足的总督和将军之流。他们完全被弄糊涂了。是的，是的。好吧，而且随后他去了圣地，不是吗？他找到了各各他（Golgotha），不是吗？……他找到了各各他，不是吗？他认为他找到了……所以他声称是的，你实际上仍然可以在耶路撒冷看到它——所以它是花园里的墓穴——所以它不是圣墓教堂，对吧？它基本上是“骷髅山”（Skull Hill），是叫骷髅山吗？是的，所以它在老城外面。对于戈登的说法有什么可信度吗？
claim no I don't think so. But I've been there. I mean, it looks more like you would hope it would look. Right. So he's doing all that. And also, I think he's, I mean, he's just kind of, I mean, he's being mad. That's harsh, Tom. That's a bit harsh. He's just spending too much time on his own.
不，我不这么认为。但我去过那里。我的意思是，它看起来比你希望它看起来的样子更像。对吧。所以他在做所有这些事情。而且，我认为他……我的意思是，他只是有点……我的意思是，他在发疯。这太刻薄了，汤姆。这有点刻薄。他只是花了太多时间独自一人。
Well, there's a lot of that stuff that you get um you know where places in the holy land are kind of secret clues to lost civilizations all that kind of thing i mean he is an 1880s version of of those kind of books yeah um you know atlantis or aliens or something like that that's kind of what he's doing but then in 1884 he as you say he he signs up to go to the congo as an agent for leopold ii who is an out-and-out baddie. It's really interesting, isn't it, Tom, to think how different this podcast would be if he'd then gone to the Congo, isn't it?
好吧，有很多那种东西，你知道，圣地的地方是通往失落文明的秘密线索，所有那类事情——我的意思是，他是那种书籍的1880年代版本。是的，……你知道，亚特兰蒂斯或外星人或诸如此类的事情，这正是他在做的事情。但随后在1884年，正如你所说，他签约去刚果担任利奥波德二世的特工，而利奥波德二世是一个彻头彻尾的坏蛋。汤姆，这真的很趣，不是吗，去想象如果他当时去了刚果，这个播客会有多么不同，不是吗？
I mean, our whole... Well, he would... Leopold II is basically using Gordon to try and kind of Christian wash it. Yeah. Isn't it? I mean, Victorian hero wash it. Yeah. Isn't it? I mean, Victorian hero wash it. Yeah. He wants him to go so that his, you know,
我的意思是，我们的整个……好吧，他会……利奥波德二世基本上是利用戈登来试图进行某种基督教洗白。是的。不是吗？我的意思是，维多利亚时代的英雄洗白。是的。不是吗？我的意思是，维多利亚时代的英雄洗白。是的。他想让他去，这样他的……
what is effectively a private estate that will be brutally, brutally run. He's doing the same with Stanley as well, the American explorer. I don't think Gordon would have tolerated that for a minute. No, he probably wouldn't have. I mean, he's not the man to do that at all. But he really thinks that he's going to go to the Congo and end slavery.
一个实际上会被残酷、残酷管理的私人领地……他也在对美国探险家斯坦利（Stanley）做同样的事。我不认为戈登会容忍哪怕一分钟。不，他可能不会。我的意思是，他根本不是那种会做这种事的人。但他真的以为他要去刚果并终结奴隶制。
I mean, this is the sort of strange, twisted, as you said, the sort of weird contradictory nature of African-European high politics and diplomacy in the 1880s, that Leopold II tells Gordon, I want you to come and we can end the slave trade together. You can end it in the Congo. What he really wants to do is to use Gordon as the front man for his operation in which he will basically have Congolese slaves working for him. Yeah.
我的意思是，这就是那种奇怪的、扭曲的，正如你所说的那种诡异矛盾的本质：1880年代非洲-欧洲的高层政治与外交，利奥波德二世告诉戈登：“我希望你来，我们可以一起结束奴隶贸易。你可以在刚果结束它。”他真正想做的是利用戈登作为他行动的门面，在这个行动中，他基本上会让刚果奴隶为他工作。是的。
And I think Gordon is starting to rumble this before he goes, because he makes a comment, huge apologies to Bart Van Loo and to all our Belgian listeners. But Gordon says, I do not like Belgians. Yeah. And I think not like Belgians. Yeah. And I think that's... Hercule Poirot. Yes.
而且我认为戈登在他去之前就开始察觉到这一点了，因为他发表了一个评论——向巴特·范·洛（Bart Van Loo）和我们所有的比利时听众致以诚挚的歉意——但戈登说：“我不喜欢比利时人。”是的。而且我认为……不喜欢比利时人。是的。而且我认为那是……赫ercule Poirot（大侦探波洛）。是的。
I think that's because he's starting to feel that Leopold perhaps is up to a dirty one. But he's been in Brussels, hasn't he? And then he comes home from Brussels in January 1884 when he's dithering about whether to accept these this offer of going to the congo and he arrives in england to find a telegram from a journalist called wt stead who is the by far the most famous kind of muckraking newspaper editor of the day this guy who runs the palma gazette and he's also a very keen spiritualist
我想那是因为他开始觉得利奥波德可能在搞什么鬼把戏。但他去过布鲁塞尔，不是吗？然后他在1884年1月从布鲁塞尔回到家里，当时他还在犹豫是否要接受去刚果的这个邀请，他到达英格兰后发现了一封电报，来自一个名叫W.T.斯泰德（W.T. Stead）的记者，此人是当时最著名的无冕之王、 muckraking（揭丑）报纸编辑，这个家伙经营着《帕尔马公报》（Pall Mall Gazette），而且他也是一个非常热衷于招魂术的人。
do you know the story of his daughter and the ghost i don't would you like to tell me i'd love to so so their house was on smith square which is where tory central offices and now the european union embassy so sted and his daughter estelle lived there. And Sted then goes on to drown on the Titanic. But before he gets drowned on the Titanic, his daughter Estelle is, she's lying in bed. She gets woken up by a man who comes into her room, slams the door open, takes off his hat, sits down at a desk, begins writing uh ignores her completely and the same thing happens three nights in a row and estelle has no idea what's going on who is this strange guy who's wandering into her room and sitting down and writing so the father suggests
你知道他女儿和鬼魂的故事吗？不知道。你想告诉我吗？我很乐意。所以，他们的房子在史密斯广场（Smith Square），也就是现在保守党总部和欧洲联盟使馆所在地。所以斯泰德和他的女儿埃斯特尔（Estelle）住在那里。斯泰德后来在泰坦尼克号沉没时溺水身亡。但在他在泰坦尼克号溺水身亡之前，他的女儿埃斯特尔正躺在床上。她被一个走进她房间的男人吵醒了，那人猛地推开门，脱下帽子，在一张桌子旁坐下，开始写字……完全无视她。连续三个晚上都是如此，埃斯特尔完全不知道发生了什么事——这个走进她的房间并坐下来写字的陌生人到底是谁？于是父亲建议……
um that they get hold of a spirit indicator because the obvious solution is that it's a ghost and this spirit indicator is a kind of device for communicating with the dead so the cell does that sounds great and the spirit indicator reveals that this it is a ghost and he's a chap called gordon knight a minor poet who specialized in rollicking songs of the sea and like a sea shanty kind of character and he and Estelle get on tremendously well. And they're great pals. And they have a lovely time. And the ghost stops slamming the door. You know, he behaves very responsibly. And when Stead then drowns in the Titanic,
他们找一个“精神指示器”（spirit indicator），因为显而易见的解决办法是这是一个鬼魂。而这个精神指示器是一种与死者沟通的设备。于是埃斯特尔照做了，听起来很棒。精神指示器显示，这是一个鬼魂，他是一个名叫约翰·戈登（John Gordon）的家伙，一个专长于创作喧闹的海上歌曲、有点像海员号子那类角色的次要诗人。他和埃斯特尔相处得非常融洽。他们是好朋友。他们玩得很开心。鬼魂停止了摔门。你知道，他表现得非常负责任。而当斯泰德后来在泰坦尼克号中溺水身亡时，
the ghost keeps her in touch with her dead father. He keeps in touch with Stead. So the ghost is seeing Sted, who's dead, because he's now drowned in the Titanic. And so he then comes and reassures Estelle that her dad's okay. Well, that's nice. So it's a very happy story.
这个鬼魂让她与死去的父亲保持联系。他与斯泰德保持联系。所以鬼魂一直在看望已经死去的斯泰德，因为他现在在泰坦尼克号中溺水身亡了。于是鬼魂随后赶来安慰埃斯特尔，告诉她爸爸没事。好吧，这挺好的。所以这是一个非常快乐的故事。
Did Estelle and the ghost keep in touch for the rest of Estelle's life? I don't know. Wow. That's an unexpected byway of the John Gordon story. But I suppose in a way it is, because it does show that people are believing quite a lot of old stuff at this point.
埃斯特尔和那个鬼魂在埃斯特尔余下的生命里一直保持联系吗？我不知道。哇。那是约翰·戈登故事中一个意想不到的小插曲。但我想从某种程度上讲确实是，因为这确实表明，在这个时候，人们对很多老旧的东西深信不疑。
Anyway, so Stead says to Gordon, I'd really like to talk to you. So Gordon, I think the next day after he's arrived, or a couple of days, says, yeah, fine, all right, we'll meet up for this interview. And at the interview, Gordon gets out a map of the Congo to show Stead all his plans for the Congo, and Stead says, well, I'm not interested in the Congo.
无论如何，斯泰德对戈登说：“我真的很想和你谈谈。”所以戈登，我想在他抵达的第二天或者几天后，说：“好吧，行，没问题，我们见个面做个采访吧。”在采访中，戈登拿出一张刚果地图，向斯泰德展示他所有关于刚果的计划，而斯泰德却说：“我对刚果不感兴趣。”
Are you not keeping up with, you know, the big news is the Sudan. So basically, it's all kicked off in the Sudan. Egypt has been embroiled in a nationalist uprising, which the British have helped to put down. And in this sort of general sort of chaos and fragmentation of egypt and also in the huge disruption in the in the sudan caused by the attempts to suppress slave hunting and the slave trade there has begun this great islamist uprising that's what we call it now, isn't it? Under a guy called Muhammad Ahmad, who basically says, I am the Mahdi.
难道你没有跟上……你知道，最大的新闻是苏丹吗？所以基本上，苏丹的一切都爆发了。埃及卷入了民族主义起义，英国人协助将其镇压。在这种埃及的普遍混乱和解体中，以及在苏丹由于试图镇压奴隶狩猎和奴隶贸易而产生的巨大动荡中，爆发了这场伟大的伊斯兰主义起义——这就是我们现在对它的称呼，不是吗？在一个名叫穆罕默德·艾哈迈德（Muhammad Ahmad）的家伙领导下，他基本上说：“我是马赫迪（Mahdi）。”
Now, Tom, you will know far better than me what all this is about, the Mahdi business. So it's this idea that there's a kind of succession of significant figures who will, in the long run, herald the second coming of Jesus and the end of the world. And it's, it's,
现在，汤姆，你肯定比我更清楚这一切是关于什么的，关于马赫迪的事业。所以这就是这样一种想法：存在着一连串重要的历史人物，从长远来看，他们将预示着耶稣的再次降临和世界的终结。而且它……
so it kind of has the same kind of apocalyptic expression that you get with the Islamic state. Or the type being rebellion. Yeah, but this is, yes, yes. But this is,
它带有那种你在伊斯兰国身上看到的同样的末日论表达。或者太平天国起义。是的，但这……是的，是的。但这……
it's Islamic. Yeah. And so it's expressive of that kind of same yearning for an establishment of a perfect Islamic order that has been massively, massively enhanceddi is expressive of that in the same way that Al-Qaeda and the Taliban and the Islamic State in more recent years have been. We've talked about lots of similar things on this podcast, haven't we, Tom? Like the Taiping, Al-Qaeda, the ghost dance, exactly, in the United States and I think I think that um Taiping uh jihadism I think we can legitimately call it that um in the 19th century um the ghost dance all of these are expressions of a kind of spiritual anguish in the face of the power of the western empires um and it's it's an anguish that different societies evolve different ways to cope you know how deal with it. And in the Muslim world, Islam has remained the great wellspring for yearnings and dreams of ending Western intrusion and authority and power right the way up to the
它是伊斯兰的。是的。因此，它表达了那种对建立完美伊斯兰秩序的渴望，这种渴望被极大地、极大地增强了……马赫迪就表达了这一点，就像近年来基地组织、塔利班和伊斯兰国所做的那样。我们在本期播客中讨论过许多类似的事情，不是吗，汤姆？比如太平天国、基地组织、美国的鬼神舞（ghost dance）等等，我认为……我认为……太平天国……圣战主义，我想我们可以合法地称之为19世纪的圣战主义……鬼神舞，所有这些都是面对西方帝国力量时精神痛苦的一种表达……而且这种痛苦是不同社会演变出不同方式来应对的，你知道，如何处理它。在穆斯林世界，伊斯兰教一直是终结西方入侵、权威和权力的渴望与梦想的伟大源泉，一直延续到……
present. So that's why, you know, we said, I think in the first episode that this is a punctuation point in the story that leads from Napoleon's intrusion into Egypt, which we've done an episode on right the way up to the story of 9-11 and its aftermath.
今天。这就是为什么，你知道的，正如我们在第一期节目中所说，这是从拿破仑入侵埃及（我们做过一期节目）一直延伸到9·11事件及其后果的故事中的一个标点符号。
And it's, it kind of, you see, because Gordon does not think that the mardi is religious that's the fascinating thing he's so religious himself but he says to stead well the mardi is not really a religious figure i think basically because gordon is so fixated on ending the slave trade and he he knows that there's a lot of discontent in the sudan about about that from the slave hunters. So I think he thinks that the Mahdi is merely the sort of figurehead
而且，它有点……你看，因为戈登不认为马赫迪是宗教性质的——这才是最迷人的地方。他自己如此笃信宗教，但他对斯泰德说：“嗯，马赫迪并不是真正的宗教人物。”我想主要是因为戈登太执着于结束奴隶贸易了，他知道苏丹有很多关于这方面的奴隶贩子引起的不满。所以我想他认为马赫迪仅仅是……
for a local uprising against the Egyptians, you know, fuelled by kind of slave hunters, and he thinks, if I can get, if you can sort out their grievances, then the Mahdi will kind of go away. I think that's what he
当地反对埃及人起义的傀儡头目，由某种奴隶贩子供应燃料，他认为，如果我能……如果你能解决他们的怨气，那么马赫迪就会消失。我想他是这么想的，不是吗？
thinks, isn't it? And it will provide an opportunity to get back to Khartoum and perhaps with British muscle behind, then we can crack on with suppressing the slave trade. Yeah. Well, this is now, this gets so confused, doesn't it? And strange, this kind of story. Okay, well, I think we should take a break there. I think when we come back,
并且这将提供一个机会回到喀土穆，也许在英国武力的支持下，然后我们就可以全力以赴地镇压奴隶贸易了。是的。好吧，现在，事情变得如此混乱，不是吗？而且奇怪，这种故事。好吧，我想我们应该在那里休息一下。我想当我们回来时，
we will look at the broader political context in Britain, which is quite complicated. And then we will go into the dramatic final year and final days of Gordon of Khartoum. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. hello welcome back um we are into the end game with our uh special on gordon of cartoon and dominic um we're gearing up to send gordon to cartoon a second time uh we're still in britain
我们将审视英国更广泛的政治背景，这相当复杂。然后我们将进入喀土穆戈登戏剧性的最后一年和最后的日子。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告广播、独家加更节目并抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回来……我们正在进入关于喀土穆戈登特别节目的尾声，多米尼克，我们正在准备第二次派戈登去喀土穆……我们仍在英国，
what's the political context for what is happening? So Britain has a liberal government under Gladstone the liberal party is a kind of very strongly anti-slavery party but it's also a non-interventionist party in many ways compared with
正在发生的事情的政治背景是什么？所以英国在格莱斯顿（Gladstone）领导下有一个自由党政府。自由党是一个非常强烈反对奴隶制的政党，但在许多方面，与……相比，它也是一个不干涉主义的政党。
the Tories. So again it's kind of like people who are very against NATO's military intervention in Afghanistan, but also are very much in favour of stopping the Taliban from approaching. Exactly. So there's a real ambivalence there. Gladstone doesn't like the idea of sending armies to overthrow regimes and so on. He's a bit ambivalent about that, not least because it's expensive and Gladstone's all about kind of keeping costs down. But there are people in the Liberal Party who think,
托利党。所以这有点像那些非常反对北约对阿富汗进行军事干预的人，但也非常赞成阻止塔利班逼近的人。完全如此。所以这里面存在着真正的矛盾心理。格莱斯顿不喜欢派遣军队推翻政权之类的想法。他对此有点矛盾，不仅仅是因为这成本高昂，而且格莱斯顿全神贯注于控制成本。但自由党里有些人认为，
there are some who think, you know, we should definitely shore up the Egyptian regime and shoring up the Sudan is part of that. There are some who passionately want to end slavery and see it as an opportunity to do that. So while they're all sort of debating, what are we going to do about the Sudan, where there's this big uprising, this sort of, as you say,
有些人认为，你知道，我们绝对应该巩固埃及政权，而巩固苏丹是其中的一部分。有些人热切希望结束奴隶制，并将其视为这样做的机会。所以当他们都在争论我们该如何处理苏丹问题时，苏丹那里发生了这场大起义，这场，正如你所说，
jihadist uprising, and the Egyptian regime wants to do something about it. While they're doing that, W.T. Stead publishes his article, his interview with Gordon. The interview is called Chinese Gordon on the Sudan, and there's an accompanying editorial entitled Chinese Gordon for the Sudan. And Stead basically says, I've interviewed Gordon. He's clearly the man. Send him immediately.
圣战者起义，而埃及政权想对此采取点行动。正当他们在做这件事时，W.T.斯泰德发表了他的文章，即对戈登的采访。这次采访名为《中国戈登谈苏丹》，并附有一篇题为《为苏丹选择中国戈登》的社论。斯泰德基本上说：“我采访了戈登。他显然就是那个人。立即派他去吧。”
He'll sort it out. And newspaper boys are sort of shouting these on the streets of London. All the other papers pile in. Say, yes, yes, yes. Send Chinese Gordon. He's the man. So this is the British tabloid press. The tabloid press, well, the equivalent to the tabloid press,
“他会解决的。”报童们在伦敦街头大声叫卖这些。其他所有的报纸都蜂拥而上。说：“对，对，对。派中国戈登去。他就是那个人。”所以这就是英国的小报新闻界。小报新闻界——好吧，相当于小报新闻界，
absolutely sort of stir this up. press the tabloid press except well the equivalent to the tabloid press absolutely kick you know sort of stir this up now you mentioned i think in our first podcast about gordon's great mate garnet walsley who had he'd become pals with in the crimea and garnet walsley is the number two man in the army to friend of the show the duke of Cambridge, who is totally useless. The most incompetent commander-in-chief ever. So Garnet Worsley despises the Duke of Cambridge. Worsley is Britain's top general, but he wants to really run the army himself. He's got a whole network of other generals called the Worsley Ring around him who are kind of modernisers and so on.
绝对是在煽动这个。报纸……小报新闻界，除了……好吧，相当于小报新闻界的家伙绝对会挑起……你知道，把这煽动起来。现在你提到了，我想在我们的第一场播客中，关于戈登的好搭档加内特·沃尔斯利（Garnet Wolseley），他在克里米亚时就跟他结成了好友，加内特·沃尔斯利是陆军的二号人物，是节目之友剑桥公爵（Duke of Cambridge）的朋友，剑桥公爵完全是个废物。是有史以来最无能的总司令。所以加内特·沃尔斯利鄙视剑桥公爵。沃尔斯利是英国顶级将军，但他真的想自己掌控军队。他身边有一整群其他将军，被称为“沃尔斯利集团”（Wolseley Ring），他们是现代主义者之类的。
I think, and I think quite a few historians take the view, that Worsley wants to use Gordon to go to the Sudan. He wants to send Gordon to the Sudan and then go and rescue him. That's always Wolseley's plan. He's always thinking, this would be a great opportunity for us to use the army to go and sort this out. And is Wolseley doing that? What's his motivation for that?
我认为，而且相当多的历史学家也持这种观点，沃尔斯利希望利用戈登去苏丹。他想派戈登去苏丹，然后再去营救他。这一直是沃尔斯利的计划。他一直在想：“这将是我们利用军队去解决这个问题的绝佳机会。”沃尔斯利这么做是在干什么？他这样做的动机是什么？
It'll make his name. It'll allow him to cement his control over the army it'll and over sudan i mean is it i don't think nobody wants nobody wants sudan for the sudan there's nothing there that people want there's no i mean the only later on the french the french and the british want sudan to complete the jigsaw puzzle of their African empires. But nobody wants it for that reason at this point. I think it's more about prestige and status than anything else. So basically, Wolseley helps to persuade the Liberal government, not Gladstone, because Gladstone's away.
这会让他声名鹊起。这会让他巩固对军队的控制，并对苏丹……我的意思是，是不是……没有人想要为了苏丹而要苏丹，那里没有什么人们想要的东西，没有……我的意思是，只有后来法国人——法国人和英国人想要苏丹来完成他们非洲帝国的拼图。但此时没有人为了这个原因想要它。我认为这更多是关于声望和地位，而不是其他任何事情。所以基本上，沃尔斯利帮助说服了自由党政府——不是格莱斯顿，因为格莱斯顿不在。
Gladstone's private secretary, W.W. Hamilton, he seems to be a half-cracked fatalist. And that's before Gordon's even gone. Lots of Gladstone's people say, sending Gordon is absolutely demented. He's the worst possible person you could send because he's all about the Garden of Eden and stuff these days.
格莱斯顿的私人秘书W.W.汉密尔顿（W.W. Hamilton）似乎是一个半疯的宿命论者。而在戈登甚至还没出发之前就是这样。格莱斯顿的许多手下都说，派戈登去绝对是疯狂的。他是你能派出的最糟糕的人选，因为他这些天满脑子都是伊甸园之类的东西。
And also, he doesn't follow orders. He's reading his Bible and making up his own mind, and he doesn't do orders. You know, he's reading his Bible and making up his own mind and he doesn't do as he's told. But he gets summoned to the war office on the 18th of January and there are four different cabinet ministers there. There's Lord Hartington,
而且，他也不听从命令。他在读圣经，自己拿主意，根本不服从调遣。你知道的，他在读圣经，自己做决定，根本不按命令行事。但在1月18日，他被传唤到战争办公室，那里有四位不同的内阁大臣。有哈廷顿勋爵，
there's a guy called Charles Dilker, there's Lord Granville, Lord Northbrook. And they basically say to him, well, we've heard you're the man, you know, are you going to go to the Sudan and all this sort of thing. Now what? Was Churchill there then? No, that's why generic. Well, Churchill've heard you're the man. Are you going to go to the Sudan and all this sort of thing? Now, what? Was Churchill there then?
有一个叫查尔斯·迪尔克的人，还有格兰维尔勋爵、诺斯布鲁克勋爵。他们基本上对他说，嗯，我们听说你就是那个人，你知道的，你要去苏丹诸如此类的吗？现在怎么着？丘吉尔当时在那儿吗？不，这就是为什么说这很泛泛。好吧，丘吉尔听说你就是那个人。你要去苏丹诸如此类的吗？现在，怎么着？丘吉尔当时在那儿吗？
No. That's why generic. Well, Churchill was a liberal. He was a senior liberal minister too, Tom, only a few years later. That's just a generic late Victorian Edwardian minister's voice. Hello, Gordon. Come in. Sit down.
没有。这就是为什么说很泛泛。好吧，丘吉尔是个自由派。汤姆，他几年后也是一位高级自由派大臣。这只是维多利亚时代晚期和爱德华时代早期内阁大臣的典型语气。你好，戈登。请进。请坐。
So go on. Anyway, there he is. What's not clear is what they tell him to do so they think they've told gordon go to the sudan bite them on the beaches no they say find out it's a fact-finding mission only so they think he's going to go and report back on the situation. What's going on in Khartoum? Report back. He seems to have thought that it's his job to evacuate the Khartoum garrison and everybody in Khartoum and get them out before the Mahdi arrives. But what also seems to be the case is that at some point in his mind, the idea takes shape. He could just go down there and run it.
所以继续吧。不管怎样，他就在那儿。不清楚的是他们到底让他做什么，所以他们以为自己告诉了戈登：去苏丹，在海滩上痛击他们——不，他们说去查明情况，这只是一次事实调查任务，所以他们以为他是去调查并汇报情况的。喀土穆发生了什么？汇报情况。他似乎认为自己的职责是撤离喀土穆的守军以及喀土穆的所有人，在马赫迪到达之前把他们救出来。但似乎也是在某种情况下，在他的脑海中，这个想法成形了：他可以直接去那里并接管控制权。
Yeah. And some people think he gets that idea later, but some people think he had that idea from the very beginning. He basically thinks, I should be in charge from the start. But it's floating around in London even before he leaves because there's a Tory peer who says of what Gordon is planning to do. Since the days of Knight Errantry, never was such an expedition taken. So there's clearly all kinds of different perspectives on what's going to happen in London.
是的。有些人认为他后来才产生这个想法，但也有人认为他从一开始就有这个想法。他基本上认为，我从一开始就该负责。但这个想法在伦敦甚至在他离开之前就已经在流传了，因为有一位托利党贵族对戈登的计划这样评价：自骑士游侠时代以来，从未有过这样的远征。因此，对于伦敦将要发生的事情，显然存在各种不同的看法。
Just as maybe there are in Gordon's head. That's the thing. Nobody really has ironed out why Gordon is going and what he's going to do. And what they're going to do and what is going you know what they're going to do once he gets there would it be uh going too far to say that the the uncertainty reflects the massive kind of moral uncertainty that britain feels about what the purpose of the british empire is is it maybe does it you know does the british Empire exist to do good, to suppress slavery, to stop elephants being wiped out? Or does it exist to stop the French from occupying territory?
正如戈登脑海中可能也有各种看法一样。问题就在这里。没有人真正理清戈登为什么要去，他打算做什么。他们要做什么，以及——你知道的——当他到达那里后他们要做什么。如果说这种不确定性反映了英国对大英帝国使命所在的某种巨大道德迷茫，这会不会……会不会有点过头了？你知道的，大英帝国存在的目的是为了行善、为了压制奴隶制、为了阻止大象被灭绝吗？还是为了阻止法国人占领领土？
Or does it exist to serve the interests of realpolitik and ensure that the Egyptian government stays in place so that they continue to screw it with money? Maybe all those things. And in a sense, Gordon is he's such a loose cannon yeah but maybe this is why it has the impact that it does because his expedition focuses all the tensions and ambivalences and contradictions that are that british imperialism particularly in africa is generating but not just british imperialism right i mean do you not think there are elements of this when you you think about our podcast that we did about afghanistan um yes we've talked about the 9-11 and the rear the yeah i'm just saying specifically africa because it's it because slavery is so
或者它的存在是为了服务于现实政治的利益，并确保埃及政府能够维持下去，以便他们继续用金钱榨取它？也许所有这些因素都有。从某种意义上说，戈登他就是一颗不受控制的炸弹。是的，但也许这就是为什么它会产生这种影响，因为他的远征集中了英国帝国主义（特别是在非洲）正在产生的所有紧张局势、矛盾心理和矛盾，但不仅仅是英国帝国主义，对吧？我的意思是，当你想到我们关于阿富汗的播客时，难道你不认为其中也有这些因素吗？嗯，是的，我们谈到了9·11事件和——是的，我只是具体指非洲，因为它——因为奴隶制在
important to the story yeah i think that's fair enough and and and the anti-slavery thing by the way will be a feature a little bit later because there's an unexpected irony of this because of the anti-slavery cause gordon's not allowed to have the allies that he wants to have but anyway they've had this meeting they sent a telegram to the queen we'd like to send chinese gordon the queen loves this idea queen victoria she thinks it's absolutely brilliant she's a great fan lots of underlinings and her yeah she's like absolutely hurrah this is he's a marvelous man yes that was almost my bit of margaret thatcher there i thought tom um it's absolutely marvelous of underlinings in her letters. Yeah, she's like, absolutely, hurrah, this is the best thing you can do. He's a marvellous man. Yes. That was almost a bit of Margaret Thatcher there, I thought, Tom.
这个故事中太重要了，是的，我认为这很公平，而且顺便说一句，反奴隶制这件事稍后会成为一个特点，因为这里有一个意想不到的讽刺：由于反奴隶制的事业，戈登不被允许拥有他想要盟友。但无论如何，他们开了这个会，给女王发了一封电报：我们想派中国戈登去。女王非常喜欢这个想法，维多利亚女王觉得这绝对太棒了。她是他的超级粉丝，有很多下划线，是的，她觉得太棒了，万岁，这是一个了不起的人。是的，那几乎有点玛格丽特·撒切尔的感觉了，我当时想，汤姆。这绝对太棒了——在她的信里有很多下划线。是的，她觉得太棒了，万岁，这是你能做的最好的事。他是个了不起的人。是的。我当时觉得，这几乎有点玛格丽特·撒切尔的风范了，汤姆。
It's absolutely marvellous. Right, so they take him. I mean, I think this story may be a bit apocryphal, but it's worth telling anyway because it's such a good story. They're supposed to have taken him to Charing Cross Station, basically that day,
这绝对太棒了。好吧，所以他们带走了他。我的意思是，我认为这个故事可能有点杜撰，但无论如何都值得一讲，因为这是一个太好的故事了。他们本应该基本上就在那天把他带到查令十字车站，
and put him on the eight o'clock mail train to the continent. You know, off you go. Go now. Lord Granville is reputed to have bought him his ticket. I think this turns out not to be true, but it's a good story. And the other thing is that Gordon had no money with him. He didn't carry money. So his mate, Wolseley, gives him his cash and gives him his gold watch.
把他送上开往欧洲大陆的八点钟邮件列车。你知道的，你走吧。现在就去。格兰维尔勋爵据说是给他买的车票。我想后来证明这不是真的，但这是一个好故事。另一件事是戈登身上没有带钱。他不带现金。所以他的伙伴沃尔斯利给了他现金和金表。
And they sort of wave him off. Off you go, good chap. Good luck. And suddenly, out of nowhere, Gordon, who was going to go to the Congo, is on his way to the Sudan. But he doesn't go straight there, which was the original plan. He stops in Cairo. And this adds another level of complexity because when he gets to Cairo, he's brought in to see Evelyn Baring, who is the British agent in Egypt,
他们算是挥手告别了。走吧，好伙计。祝你好运。突然之间，原本要去刚果的戈登，已经在去苏丹的路上了。但他并没有直接去那里，那是最初的计划。他在开罗停留了。这又增加了一层复杂性，因为当他到达开罗时，他被带去见埃夫林·巴林（Evelyn Baring），他是英国驻埃及的代理人，
who basically is running Egypt, and the Khedive, the ruler of Egypt. And they say to him, don't go to Khartoum to just evacuate the garrison or to do a fat-finding mission. Go to be governor general. Go and run it. And at that point, obviously, in his own mind,
基本上在管理着埃及，还有赫迪夫，埃及的统治者。他们对他说，不要只是去喀土穆撤离守军或进行事实调查任务。去当总督吧。去那里掌权。在那一刻，显而易见，在他自己的脑海里，
the meaning of his mission has changed, hasn't it? Yeah. So a lot of people would say that's the moment at which the sort of the fatal melodrama is prepared. But we should also, I mean, we said in the first part that there is a kind of a part of him that has always yearned for martyrdom. Yeah. So he's not afraid of death because death will lead him to heaven. What he keeps saying during the course of this expedition, you know, things are absolutely going to pot around me.
他使命的意义已经改变了，不是吗？是的。所以很多人会说，那就是注定的情节剧开始酝酿的时刻。但我们还应该——我的意思是，我们在第一部分说过，他内心深处有一种对殉道的渴望。是的。所以他不怕死，因为死亡会把他带向天堂。在这场远征的过程中，他不断说的是，你知道的，我周围的一切都在彻底搞砸。
It's absolute disaster. But I can't question God's plan. This is what God wants. And it would be wrong for me to try to change anything or to escape or any of these things, because that's clearly not what God is intending. So I think when he leaves... And that's very clear.
这绝对是一场灾难。但我不能质疑上帝的计划。这就是上帝想要的。如果我试图改变任何事情、逃跑或做这些事，那就是错误的，因为这显然不是上帝的意图。所以我认为当他离开时……这非常清楚。
I mean, so the French guy whose name I can't remember who also subsequently accused him of being drunk. Yeah. But says that what he did, he never did anything for political reasons. It was always for Christ and the Gospels. Yeah, everybody knows that. And that's why quite a lot of people, when they say we're sending Gordon,
我的意思是，那个法国人——我不记得他叫什么名字了，后来还指控他酗酒。是的。但他却说，他所做的事，从来都不是出于政治原因，永远是为了基督和福音。是的，人人都知道这一点。这就是为什么相当多的人在听说我们要派戈登去时，
are like, what? He's the worst person you could possibly send. I mean, you know, you're sending a sort of, people sort of say you're sending this kind of evangelical Puritan to try to save the Sudan against the Mahdi. I mean, that's completely demented. The last person, Gordon's not a pragmatist, he's not Realpolitik,
反应是：什么？他是你可能派出的最糟糕的人选。我的意思是，你知道的，你居然派了这样一个福音派清教徒去试图从马赫迪手中拯救苏丹，这简直太疯狂了。戈登绝不是一个实干家，他不懂现实政治，
he's none of these things. Anyway, off he goes. He goes on with his mate Colonel Stewart, who's his chosen second-in-command. They go south from Egypt. They go up the Nile by steamer, by railway, horses. He
他这些都不是。不管怎样，他出发了。他带着他的搭档斯图尔特上校一起走，斯图尔特是他挑选的副手。他们从埃及向南进发。他们乘轮船、乘火车、骑马沿着尼罗河逆流而上。他
arrives at the second city of Sudan, which is called Berber in February 1884 and at that point he's told the Mahdi's troops have basically cut off the route from the coast from the Red Sea so you can't evacuate Khartoum that way
于1884年2月抵达苏丹的第二大城市柏培拉，就在那时，他被告知马赫迪的军队基本上已经切断了从海岸通往红海的路线，所以你无法通过那种方式撤离喀土穆，
then you can't expect rescue that way so the job is going to be much much harder but he says you know fine we'll just keep going um yeah so they arrive at khartoum on the 18th of february 1884 and uh you at the very beginning of this epic you read out the thing from he burns all the debtors books yeah and he sort of you know he says doesn't he yeah and um the stocks and so this commits of torture he's a great performer he's a great kind of political performer and he arrives in cartoon and he clearly sees himself i mean this is what
那么你就无法指望通过那种方式获救，所以这项任务将变得难上加难。但他说，你知道的，没关系，我们会继续前进的。嗯，是的，他们在1884年2月18日抵达喀土穆，呃，在这个史诗般的故事的一开始，你宣读了关于他烧毁所有债务账本的事情，是的，他某种程度上——你知道的，他说了，不是吗？是的，还有那些库存和——所以这涉及酷刑，他是一个出色的表演者，他是一个非常擅长政治表演的人。他抵达喀土穆后，显然认为自己——我的意思是，这就是
lytton straight he brings out in his essay in eminent victorians that he sees himself as a bit of a kind of very small M, Messiah of a kind. Well, he's Christ clearing the temple. But straight away, it's obvious he's not there to report back to the liberal government in London. He's there for the long haul. So he starts to evacuate Egyptian women and children and European women and children by steamer.
利顿·斯特拉奇（Lytton Strachey）在他的《维多利亚时代名人传》一书中所揭示的，他认为自己有点像某种……带有极小m的微型弥赛亚。好吧，他就是那个洁净圣殿的基督。但很快，显而易见的是，他不是来向伦敦的自由派政府汇报工作的。他是为了长远打算而来的。因此，他开始用轮船疏散埃及妇女儿童以及欧洲妇女儿童。
But he kind of settles into the palace. He walks around in his fez. He keeps saying, you know, this is all god's plan so he writes all things are ruled by him for his glory it is rebellion to murmur against his will he's writing all this on telegrams as well isn't he yeah to bearing these telegrams what's're like, what's going on? Yes. So please advise estimated arrival of steamer and loads of quotations from the Bible. I mean, not what you want, really.
但他有点在宫殿里安顿下来了。他戴着土耳其fez帽四处走动。他不停地说，你知道的，这一切都是上帝的计划，所以他写道：万物皆由他主宰，为了他的荣耀，对他的旨意发牢骚就是叛逆。他在电报上也写了所有这些，不是吗？是的，发给巴林的这些电报，内容就像是，到底怎么回事？是的。因此，请告知轮船预计到达时间，并附上大量《圣经》引文。我的意思是，这真不是你想要的。
But all the time this has been followed by the British newspapers. So they know that Gordon has gone. And they're like, you know, Gordon is the great hero. We've got to rescue him gordon well because he doesn't doesn't stewart he gets massacred yes he does so a series of things start to go wrong so first of all gordon has said i want this guy called zubair who's a sort of a local
但所有这一切一直受到英国报纸的关注。所以他们知道戈登已经去了。他们的反应是，你知道的，戈登是大英雄。我们必须去拯救他——戈登，因为难道斯图尔特没有被屠杀吗？是的，他确实被杀了。所以一系列事情开始出错。首先，戈登说过：我想要一个叫祖拜尔的人，他是一个当地的
chief a warlord basically he is the man i need at my side to run the sudan because i've been to the sudan before and i know he has all the contacts. But Zubair is a slave hunter and a slave trader. And also the father of someone who Gordon had killed. That is also a problem. But the anti-slavery society in Britain says under no circumstances can he have Zubair. Because Zubair is a bad guy because he's a slaver. So Gladstone is told by other liberal politicians, oh, it'll cause a lot of trouble for us with the liberal grassroots.
酋长、军阀，基本上他才是我留在身边管理苏丹所需的人选，因为我以前去过苏丹，我知道他拥有所有人脉。但祖拜尔是一个奴隶猎人和奴隶贩子。而且还是戈登杀过的人的父亲。这也是个问题。但英国的反奴隶制协会表示，在任何情况下他都不能拥有祖拜尔。因为祖拜尔是个坏人，因为他是奴隶贩子。所以其他自由派政客对格莱斯顿说，哦，这会给我们的自由派基层民众带来很多麻烦。
So Gladstone says, well, he can't have Zubair. No good. So at that point, Gordon doesn't really have any local allies. And the Mahdi's army is closing in the whole time. And Bering in Cairo keeps saying to Gordon, well, you could evacuate. You could send... Well, it's very like the Taliban, isn't it?
所以格莱斯顿说，好吧，他不能拥有祖拜尔。那不行。所以在那个时候，戈登实际上没有任何当地盟友。马赫迪的军队一直在步步紧逼。开罗的巴林不断对戈登说，嗯，你可以撤离。你可以派遣——这很像塔利班，不是吗？
I mean, it's the reports coming back from Kabul saying the Taliban are closing in. But what was the analogy? Who would we send or the Americans send to Kabul that would be the equivalent of General Gordon? I mean, Tony Blair, if he'd gone personally. People would be saying, we must rescue Tony Blair before the time closes in.
我的意思是，从喀布尔传回的报告说塔利班正在逼近。但这个类比是什么？我们会派谁或者美国人会派谁去喀布尔，其地位相当于戈登将军？我的意思是，托尼·布莱尔如果亲自去的话。人们会说，我们必须在塔利班逼近之前拯救托尼·布莱尔。
Who would it be? Meghan Markle. Oh my God, Tom. Prince Harry. It would be Prince Harry. Would it be? It would be someone like Prince Harry. It's such a bizarre scenario.
会是谁呢？梅根·马克尔。噢，天哪，汤姆。哈里王子。会是哈里王子。会吗？会是像哈里王子这样的人。这真是个怪诞的场景。
I don't know. Well, because Prince Harry. It's such a bizarre scenario. I don't know. Well, because Prince Harry served in Afghanistan. He did. Yeah, I think that's the... If we sent him to be governor general and also Prince Harry... But also because he's been born again. Yeah, into whiteness.
我不知道。好吧，因为哈里王子。这真是个怪诞的场景。我不知道。好吧，因为哈里王子在阿富汗服过役。他确实服过。是的，我认为这就是——如果我们派他去当总督，而且哈里王子还——但也是因为他是重生基督徒。是的，进入了白人世界。
Yes. And he's refusing to come because he's got to save... He's got to decolonise the Afghan curriculum. He's got to decolonize the Afghan curriculum. He's got to decolonize the Afghan curriculum. Exactly. That's the analogy. Yeah. I mean, I think that's what's going on.
是的。而且他拒绝回来，因为他必须拯救——他必须去阿富汗课程进行去殖民化。他必须对阿富汗课程进行去殖民化。他必须对阿富汗课程进行去殖民化。没错。这就是类比。是的。我的意思是，我认为这就是正在发生的事情。
Well, anyway, this situation has now got completely out of control. People are saying to Gordon, you could go north, you could go south, you could get out of Khartoum. And under no circumstances am I leaving. He says, I'm not going to leave Khartoum and leave people behind. Absolutely not. I'm here for the long haul. The Mahdi, so he's the leader of the jihad,
无论如何，现在这个局势已经完全失控了。人们对戈登说，你可以向北走，你可以向南走，你可以离开喀土穆。而他在任何情况下都绝不离开。他说：我不会离开喀土穆并把人们抛在身后。绝对不。我是为了长远大局而来的。马赫迪，他是圣战的领袖，
he starts sending Gordon all these letters saying, why don't you surrender and embrace Islam? It'll be fine. We can be great pals. And in the film, Kh lawrence olivier as the mardi and charlton heston yeah don't they meet up um the gordon and the mardi actually it's not a film that gets shown a lot these days no because lawrence olivier is blacked up you see to play the uh to play the mardi charlton heston as yeah i think charlton is quite good as gordon actually
他开始给戈登写信说，你为什么不投降并皈依伊斯兰教呢？那挺好的。我们可以成为好哥们。在电影里，劳伦斯·奥利维尔（Lawrence Olivier）饰演马赫迪，查尔顿·赫斯顿（Charlton Heston）饰演——是的，他们不是见面了吗，戈登和马赫迪？其实这不是一部现在经常上映的电影，不，因为劳伦斯·奥利维尔涂黑了脸，你看，来扮演——来扮演马赫迪。查尔顿·赫斯顿饰演——是的，我觉得查尔顿在电影里演戈登其实挺好的。
in the film anyway that's by the by so gordon says no i'm not going to convert to islam you know i'm i'm still here so you know uh the margie's closing in and in britain more people getting more and more agitated and gladstone is digging his heels in gladstone says no no i'm not going to send a relief force then eventually he agrees he has to and woolsey gets what he's always wanted, which is the chance to lead the rescue, but much too late, because Gladstone has delayed and delayed. So the Wolsey expedition
不管怎样，那是题外话。所以戈登说：不，我不会皈依伊斯兰教，你知道的，我还在这里，所以你知道的，马赫迪在逼近，英国有越来越多的人变得越来越焦虑，而格莱斯顿则死守立场。格莱斯顿说：不，不，我不会派救援部队的。然后他最终同意他必须这么做，沃尔斯利得到了他一直想要的东西，那就是领导救援的机会，但为时已晚，因为格莱斯顿一拖再拖。所以沃尔斯利的远征部队
only arrives in Cairo on the 9th of September, 1884. So at this point, Gordon has been in Khartoum for, what, seven months or so? But at this point, the Mahdi is really quite close to Khartoum. So Gordon has had to put chains across rivers,
直到1884年9月9日才抵达开罗。所以此时，戈登在喀土穆已经待了大概七个月左右了吧？但此时，马赫迪实际上已经离喀土穆非常近了。所以戈登不得不把铁链横跨河流，
and he's basically formed the people of Khartoum into a kind of defence. He's giving them little metal stars for good conduct and so on. He's running the whole thing as a kind of military operation. A month afterwards, he's landed in Cairo. The kind of as a kind of military operation a month afterwards he's landed in cairo the mardi arrives outside khartoum and then you have this you know for day days and days and days the um the dervishes as they were the british called them the ansar i think as they call themselves the mardiist army they're bombarding Khartoum with cannons and rockets and so on and
他基本上把喀土穆的人民组织成了一种防御力量。他给他们颁发小金属星以表彰其良好行为等等。他把这一切当作某种军事行动来运营。在他登陆开罗一个月后，马赫迪抵达了喀土穆郊外，然后你就看到了——你知道的，日复一日，达尔维什人（英国人是这么叫他们的，安萨尔人，我想他们自己是这么叫自己的，马赫迪军队）用大炮、火箭弹等等轰炸喀土穆，
sort of rifle fire and things. And then the waters drop, don't they? They do. They do. So it's all... So, you know, it suddenly gets to the point where like, okay, this is really serious now. If the British don't arrive
还有步枪射击等等。然后水位下降了，不是吗？确实下降了。是的。所以这一切——所以，你知道的，突然到了这种地步，就像是，好吧，这下真的严重了。如果英国人再不来，
you know... Now. Now. Gordon is doomed. Gordon is up there on the roof of his palace reading his bible writing letters constantly writing you know god's will will be done and all this i thank god i don't have to go to any dinner parties this kind of stuff i don't know how the wangs are getting on the people of Khartoum have been reduced to eating dogs. It's all going horribly wrong. The British are coming south. On, I think, the 17th of January, 1885,
你知道的——现在。现在。戈登就死定了。戈登正坐在他的宫殿屋顶上读着圣经，不断地写信，写着“愿主的旨意得以成就”之类的话。我感谢上帝，我不用去参加任何晚宴，诸如此类的话。我不知道王家的人现在怎么样了。喀土穆的人民已经被迫只能吃狗肉了。这一切都变得糟透了。英国人正在向南推进。我想在1885年1月17日，
the British fight the first, the sort of vanguard, the advance guard. So the British have come in this long, long column. They have to come so slowly because they need water and they can't outpace their supply train. So it's taking forever. It's taking months. They fight the Mardiists at a place called Abu Claire, but their commander is killed.
英国人打响了第一场战斗，可以说是先头部队、先遣队。所以英国人是以一列长长的队伍行进的。他们必须走得很慢，因为他们需要水，而且不能把补给车队甩在后面。所以这花了很长时间。花了几个月的时间。他们在阿布克莱（Abu Klea）一个叫作这个地方的地方与马赫迪军队交战，但他们的指挥官阵亡了。
This is the place, Tom. You know the poem that we read out in the cricket episode, my favourite poem. Oh, about the play up, play up and play the game. Play up, play up and play the game, Vita Lampada. So the square that broke, the colonel's dead, you know, all that sort of stuff. This sort of great poem of empire that's written about this battle,
就是这个地方，汤姆。你知道我们在板球那一集里读过的那首诗，我最喜欢的诗。哦，关于“奋力拼搏，奋力拼搏，把比赛打好”。奋力拼搏，奋力拼搏，打好比赛，维塔·兰帕达（Vita Lampada）。所以防线被突破了，上校阵亡了，你知道的，诸如此类。这首关于这场战斗的伟大的帝国诗篇，
the square broke and, you know, there's all carnage. So they're going very slowly now, the relief force. Then on the 25th of January, I think it is, Gordon's up smoking on his roof, reading the Bible. But down below, the Mardius have identified, as you said, the waters have receded. And they've identified that a ditch has been left undefended or something. They can see a weakness in the defences.
防线被突破了，你知道的，到处都是大屠杀。所以救援部队现在走得很慢。然后在大约1月25日，我想是这样，戈登正坐在屋顶上抽烟、读圣经。但在下面，正如你所说，马赫迪军队已经发现水位退去了。他们发现有一条沟渠防守空虚或者诸如此类的漏洞。他们能看出防线的弱点。
And first thing the next morning the 26th of january two days before gordon's birthday yeah they break into cartoon what follows is utter utter carnage thousands of people being massacred being beheaded all europeans basically being one of them Gordon. Well, we don't know what happens to Gordon. So the famous story... Well, we know he got beheaded. We know that, but... And we know he died. We don't know how. And the famous, the image that became one of the absolute defining images,
第二天一早，也就是1月26日，在戈登生日前两天，是的，他们冲进了喀土穆。接下来发生的是彻底的、绝对的大屠杀，成千上万的人被屠杀、被斩首，所有的欧洲人基本上——其中之一就是戈登。嗯，我们不知道戈登遭遇了什么。所以那个著名的故事——嗯，我们知道他被斩首了。我们知道这一点，但是……而且我们知道他死了。但我们不知道是怎么死的。那个著名的、成为最具决定性的图像之一的画面，
not just of Victorian Britain, but of European Empire, I would say. And the relationship between Europe and Africa or Asia and so on is George William Joy's painting which you can see online if you don't know it of Gordon standing there imperturbable in his fez in his suit um on the steps of the palace and this sort of great crowd of dervishes with spears facing him and that's the like that the image at the end of the charlton heston film which recreates it to the letter charlton heston
我不仅指在维多利亚时代的英国，也可以说是整个欧洲帝国。我认为欧洲与非洲或亚洲等地的关系，就体现在乔治·威廉·乔伊（George William Joy）的那幅画中——如果你不知道它，可以在网上看到——画的是戈登穿着他的土耳其fez帽和西装，面不改色地站在宫殿台阶上，面前是一大群拿着长矛的达尔维什人。这就是查尔顿·赫斯顿电影结尾的那个画面，它一字不差地重现了那一幕。查尔顿·赫斯顿
looks regal you know he looks but there are there are reports aren't there that he he he he fights yeah until he runs out of ammunition and then gets overwhelmed. But isn't it further complicating it? I mean, he writes, he's debating whether he should accept death or if he gets captured, what should he then do? And he says that perhaps capture will be a kind of calvary for him, a kind of... What an extraordinary thing to be thinking though, Tom, isn't it?
看起来很有王者风范，你知道的，他看起来——但也有报道说，他——他——他一直在战斗，直到弹药耗尽，然后被压倒。但这难道不是让事情变得更复杂了吗？我的意思是，他写道，他正在纠结自己是该接受死亡，还是如果被俘了又该怎么做？他说，也许被俘对他来说会是一种受难（Calvary），一种……汤姆，这真是一个非同寻常的想法，不是吗？
Yeah, it is. To be weighing up in your mind. Yeah. I mean, there are some accounts, aren't there, that he... Well, the Mahdi wanted him alive. He did. There's one account
是的，确实如此。在脑海中权衡这些。是的。我的意思是，有些记载说他——好吧，马赫迪想留他活口。他确实想。有一个记载
that Gordon bared his breast to the dervishes and shouted, strike, and one of them plunged a spear into his chest. I mean, there are numerous different versions.
说戈登向达尔维什人挺起胸膛大喊：“刺吧！”，其中一人把长矛刺进了他的胸膛。我的意思是，有许多不同的版本。
But we know he does die against the Mahdi's wishes who wanted him captured. And he does get beheaded. And the head gets taken to the Mahdi. Yeah. And the body is thrown down a well, I think. And never gets found. And two days later, the British steamers turn up outside Khartoum.
但我们知道他确实死了，违背了想要活捉他的马赫迪的意愿。而且他确实被斩首了。他的头被带给了马赫迪。是的。尸体被扔进了一口井里，我想。而且再也没有找到。两天后，英国的轮船出现在了喀土穆郊外。
Two days, Tom. And they don't even land, do they? No, they arrive and I think they realise. And Wolves' great expedition, he's called home. He sends a furious, furious telegram to Queen Victoria and blames Gladstone for the whole thing. So Gladstone, the grand old man, the GOM, gets inverted to become MOG, the murder of Gordon.
就差两天，汤姆。而且他们甚至都没有登陆，对吧？不，他们到了，我想他们意识到了。沃尔斯利的那支伟大的远征部队，他被召回了。他给维多利亚女王发了一封愤怒至极的电报，并将这一切归咎于格莱斯顿。所以格莱斯顿，这位伟大的老人（GOM），被倒转过来变成了MOG，也就是“谋杀戈登的人”（Murderer of Gordon）。
I mean, when the news reached Britain, there was a Princess Diana style. And around the world, I think. Explosion. I mean, am I not right in thinking that there were signs with black borders in Boston and New York and so on? All around the world.
我的意思是，当消息传到英国时，出现了一种戴安娜王妃式的轰动。我想全世界也是如此。大爆发。难道我没记错的话，波士顿和纽约等地都挂出了带黑边的标语吗？全世界都是如此。
Even in Germany. You know, that Gordon, the hero of Christian Western civilization, had been abandoned and betrayed and left to die in Khartoum, killed by the dervishes. You know, it's a story that could have been dreamed up by some sort of... By the enemies of slave traders and so many knots of paradox and complexity. And then further adding to that is then what happens in 1898 when... Yeah, the British return.
甚至在德国也是。你知道的，基督教西方文明的英雄戈登，竟然被抛弃、背叛，任其在喀土穆死去，死于达尔维什人之手。你知道的，这是一个可以由某种……由奴隶贩子的敌人编造出来、充满无数悖论和复杂性的故事。随之更加增添这种复杂性的是1898年发生的事情——是的，英国人卷土重来。
The British return and wipe the Maldives army out of the Battle of Omdurman on the other side of the Nile from Khartoum. Which Churchill is present at. Churchill writes about Omdurman brilliantly, by the way, in his book, The River War, because he was with the 21st Lancers. So they think they're there. I mean, they're not really there to avenge Gordon. That's what they're told, aren't they? They're there to stymie the French. And isn't it right that it's commanded by Kitchener, who had known Gordon?
英国人卷土重来，在尼罗河对岸喀土穆的恩图曼战役中彻底消灭了马赫迪的军队。丘吉尔也亲历了这场战役。顺便说一句，丘吉尔在他的书《河流之战》中对恩图曼之战进行了精彩的记述，因为他当时随第21枪骑兵团作战。所以他们认为他们在那儿。我的意思是，他们去那儿其实并不是为了替戈登报仇。人们是这么告诉他们的，对吧？他们去那儿是为了阻挠法国人。难道不是由认识戈登的基奇纳（Kitchener）指挥的吗？
Yes, that's right. And after the battle, he opens up the orders and gets told, actually, it's nothing to do with Gordon. You've got to go and stop the French. But Kitchener made a point of despoiling the tomb of the Mahdi. The Mahdi was dead by this point. Kitchener had the Mahdi's tomb kind of, you know, his bones destroyed or thrown into a river or something. And as vengeance.
是的，没错。战斗结束后，他打开命令一看，才被告知实际上这与戈登毫无关系。你得去阻止法国人。但基奇纳特意毁坏了马赫迪的陵墓。马赫迪此时已经死了。基奇纳让人把马赫迪的陵墓——你知道的，把他的骨头毁掉或者扔进河里什么的。以此作为报复。
Yeah. And who is it? Reginald Wingate, who was another one of the officers. And Douglas Haig as well, wasn't he? He, exactly. He supposedly got hold of the skull of the martyr's successor, who was called the Khalifa, and he had it made into a cup. And he used to drink champagne out of it, Tom,
是的。是谁干的？雷金纳德·温盖特（Reginald Wingate），他是另一位军官，还有道格拉斯·黑格（Douglas Haig），对吧？他，确切地说，他据说是拿到了马赫迪继承人（被称为哈里发）的头骨，把它做成了一个杯子。他每年都会用它喝香槟，汤姆，
on the anniversary of the Battle of Omdurman every year until 1953. Goodness. And they were able to do that what is it? Because we have got... The Gatling Gum. And they have not. But the shock of Gordon's death
在每年恩图曼战役的纪念日上，一直持续到1953年。天哪。他们之所以能做到这一点，是因为什么？因为我们拥有——加特林机枪。而他们没有。但戈登之死的震惊，
the way in which he was turned into a martyr so Robert Louis Stevenson said, England stands before the world dripping with blood and daubed with dishonour. And this sort of sense that Gordon was, he's not just a martyr, he's not a hero, he's positively a saint. I mean, this is what...
他被塑造成烈士的方式——所以罗伯特·路易斯·史蒂文森（Robert Louis Stevenson）说：“英格兰站在世界面前，浑身滴血，涂满耻辱。”这种感觉是，戈登不仅是烈士，他不是英雄，他简直就是个圣徒。我的意思是，这就是——
Christ-like, Christ-like. Genuinely Christ-like. So this is what Wolseley said. Wolseley, where are you? Wolseley said Wolseley um where Wolseley said he's gone from amongst us and I shall never know his like again indeed many generations may come and go without producing a Charlie Gordon his example will be one that fathers will hold up to their sons in England and as long as any faith in God remains to us as a nation and that we continue to be manly enough to revere the highest
基督般的，基督般的。真正像基督一样。所以这就是沃尔斯利说的。沃尔斯利，你在哪儿？沃尔斯利说——沃尔斯利，呃，在哪儿？沃尔斯利说他已经离我们而去，我再也见不到像他这样的人了。事实上，许多代人来来往往，也未必能培养出一个查理·戈登。他的榜样将是英格兰的父亲们向儿子们灌输的榜样，只要我们作为国家的对上帝的信仰犹存，只要我们继续保持足够的男子气概去崇敬最高形式的
form of courage and devotion to duty. This is a letter to Gordon's brother. So long will your brother be quoted and referred to as the human embodiment of all manly and Christian virtues. And this was, I mean, widespread in Britain and the English-speaking world in the 1880s, the sense that Gordon was the embodiment of Western civilization and Christian civilization. Do you not think, Tom? I do. And I also think that that is then what gets reacted against, most famously by Strachey.
勇气和对职责的忠诚。这是写给戈登兄弟的一封信。只要这样，你的兄弟就会被引用和提及，作为所有男子气概和基督教美德的人类化身。我的意思是，这在18世纪80年代（注：应为19世纪80年代）的英国和英语世界广泛流传，人们认为戈登是西方文明和基督教文明的化身。难道你不这么认为吗，汤姆？我是这么认为的。而且我也认为，这正是后来遭到强烈反弹的原因，其中最著名的就是斯特拉奇（Strachey）。
Yes. So the last lines of his biography of Gordon, the future lay with Major Kitchener and his Maxim Nordenfelt guns. 13 years later, the Mahdi's empire was abolished forever in the gigantic Hecatomb of Omdurman. And then he has this very famous last line. At any rate, it had all ended very happily in a glorious slaughter of 20,000 Arabs,
是的。所以他那本关于戈登的传记的最后几行是：未来属于基奇纳少校和他的马克沁·诺登菲尔特机关枪。13年后，马赫迪的帝国在恩图曼巨大的百人祭杀戮中永远消失了。然后他写下了那句非常著名的结语：无论如何，这一切都非常幸福地结束了，伴随着对2万阿拉伯人的辉煌屠杀、
a vast addition to the British Empire and a step in the peerage for Sir Evelyn Baring. And I guess that that would be the kind of default attitude now that anything involving British military expeditions to up the Nile is to be viewed in those terms. But I think it is much more complicated.
大英帝国的巨大扩张，以及埃夫林·巴林爵士晋升贵族的一步。我想，现在对于任何涉及英国军事远征逆尼罗河而上的行动，人们默认的态度都会是这种看法。但我认为事情要复杂得多。
Well, partly because of the slavery aspect, right? Absolutely, yes. And I think that if we're saying, well, who are Gordon's heirs today in contemporary Britain? I mean, they're to be found among people who are campaigning to return looted artefacts to Nigeria and condemning slavery and campaigning to save wildlife in Africa, as they are among the more jingoistic, perhaps. But Gordon would be a complete liberal interventionist wouldn't he i mean he would be uh you know we should be in afghanistan um protecting women from the taliban yeah he'd be all about that wouldn't he there really is his heirs i would say people who look at you know
好吧，部分原因是由于奴隶制的方面，对吧？绝对是的。而且我认为，如果我们说，好吧，在当今的当代英国，谁是戈登的继承人？我的意思是，他们可以在那些竞选将掠夺的文物归还给尼日利亚、谴责奴隶制并竞选拯救非洲野生动物的人当中找到，就像在那些更沙文主义的人当中一样。但戈登会是一个彻头彻尾的自由派干涉主义者，不是吗？我的意思是，他会——你知道的，我们应该在阿富汗保护女性免受塔利班的侵害——是的，他会全力支持这些，不是吗？这才是他的真正继承人，我会说，那些看着世界上其他地方并说我们有责任把他们带向光明的人，我会说那种基督教动机——虽然现在可能世俗化了，但它绝对存在于许多西方社会中。是的，绝对是这样。而且我认为这就是为什么这是一个如此迷人的话题。我非常赞赏你选择了这个话题。所以，我们完成了。
other parts of the world and say we have a duty to bring them into the light i would say that christian motivation is as which might be secularized now, but it's absolutely there in kind of lots of Western societies. Yeah, absolutely. And I think that that's why it's such a fascinating topic. And I thoroughly commend you having picked on it. So, so we've done.
所以这就是戈登将军。我是不是该用朗读来作结呢？我感到非常内疚，因为你——你实际上把这首诗发给了我，我非常喜欢，以至于我说：“我能读一下吗？”我已经读了
So that's a general Gordon. Shall I reach, shall I take us out by reading? I feel very bad because you, you, you actually, you sent the poem to me and I enjoyed it so much that I said, could I read it? And I've read
五节，我知道你其实也渴望来读。所以你为什么不用最后几节来为我们作结呢？好的。我不会用我的苏格兰口音、麦戈尼格尔口音来读，因为我觉得那样对戈登将军很不尊重。只是别用你那种带引号的丘吉尔腔调就行。哦，当然。
five of the verses and I know that you were dying to. So why don't you take us out with the last few verses? Okay. I won't do it in my Scottish accent, my McGonagall accent, because I think that would be disrespectful to General Gordon. Just don't do it in your inverted commas Churchill. Oh, indeed.
是的，好吧，我可以用你那种尼安德特人的声音来读，我想，但那绝对是对戈登将军的不敬。那确实非常不敬。好吧，我们开始吧。他总是乐于为穷人主持会议，也为他们设法筹措肉类和衣物。他总是能随口说出幽默的小笑话，因为那不是真的——
Yeah, well, I could do it in your Neanderthal voice, I suppose, but that definitely would be disrespectful to General Gordon. It would be very disrespectful. OK, here we go. He was always willing to conduct meetings for the poor, also meat and clothing for them he tried to procure. And he always had little humorous speeches at command, for that's not true.
听他讲这些一定棒极了。在军旅生涯中，再也找不到能与他匹敌的人，哪怕你搜遍整个广阔的世界。一想到他竟在喀土穆遭遇如此厄运，被一个卑鄙的叛徒恶棍所害，就令人痛心。是的，那个黑心叛徒打开了喀土穆的大门，基督教英雄由此迎来了他的末日。因为当大门被打开时，阿拉伯人疯狂地冲了进来，残忍地杀害了他，脸上还带着狞笑。但他手持斧剑进行了高尚的防御。只可惜，他很快就被那群野蛮人压倒，他的胸口挨了一百多根长矛，而他的凶手们则得意忘形地尖叫怒吼。
And to hear him deliver them, it must have been grand. In military life his equal couldn't be found, not if you were to search the wide world around, and tis pitiful to think he is met with such a doom by a base traitor knave while in Khartoum. Yes, the black-hearted traitor opened the gates of Khartoum, and through that the Christian hero has met his doom. For when the gates were opened, the Arabs rushed madly in, and foully murdered him, while they laughingly did grin. But he defended himself nobly with axe and sword in hand. But alas, he was soon overpowered by that savage band, and his body received a hundred spear- and more while his murderers exultingly did loudly shriek and roar.
但据说上天的旨意必须执行，按照他自己的看法，他的时刻已经来临。但我希望他现在已经在天堂收获他的奖赏，尽管他在大地上遭遇的命运实在非常残酷。我希望人们能永远缅怀他的记忆，以他为榜样，怀着敬畏之心崇拜上帝，永远不要对世俗钱财过于迷恋，并在他们活着的时候追随戈登将军的足迹。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听
But heaven's will, it is said, must be done and according to his own opinion his time was come. But I hope he's now in heaven reaping his reward although his fate on earth was really very hard. I hope the people will his memory revere and take an example from him and worship God in fear and never be too fond of worldly gear and walk in General Gordon's footsteps while they are here. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并访问我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。